Hey everybody. Ira Glass here. So we got this email at our radio show near the end of the last school year from a 14-year-old.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。上个学年末，我们广播节目的编辑部收到了一封邮件，发件人是一位14岁的学生。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, is this Annie?
嘿，是安妮吗？
Yes.
是的。
I called her up at her house in California and asked her to read it.
我给她加州的家里打了电话，请她读了这封邮件。
It says, "Dear This American Life, I just escaped the whitewashed, brick-walled, iron-gated prison that is commonly known as middle school, and I'm finally out for good. But in all the time I've listened to your show, I've never heard an episode devoted to what goes on inside the walls of a middle school. I hope you'll think about it. Anonymous."
上面写着：“亲爱的《美国生活》栏目，我刚刚逃离了那个被称为初中的、粉刷着白墙、砖墙铁门的监狱，我终于彻底解脱了。但在我收听你们节目的这段时间里，我从没听过哪一期节目专门讲初中围墙里到底发生了什么。我希望你们能考虑一下。——匿名者。”
Yeah, you signed it anonymous, but then your email was signed with your name.
是的，你署名是“匿名者”，但你的邮件后面却签了你的名字。
Yeah.
是的。
对。
I did anonymous because in middle school, everybody is so judgmental, and I didn't want the kids to judge me or anything if they heard me on the radio.
我之所以用匿名，是因为在初中，每个人都特别爱评头论足，如果同学们在广播里听到我的声音，我不想让他们对我评头论足。
Mainly, she says that she wrote to us because she and her friends were talking right after they left eighth grade about how terrible middle school was. And she wondered was it just as bad for other people as it was for them?
她主要说，她给我们写信是因为她和朋友们在刚离开八年级后就在谈论初中有多么糟糕。她想知道，这对其他人来说是否也和她们一样糟糕？
You always wonder whether other people are going through the same thing as you. And it'd be cool to hear other people's stories about it and what they went through.
你总是会想，别人是否也在经历和你一样的事情。如果能听到别人的故事和经历，那该多酷啊。
And if you had to explain to somebody what are the worst things about middle school-- can I ask you to just walk me through it. What is so bad about middle school?
如果你必须向别人解释初中最糟糕的事情是什么——我可以请你带我了解一下吗？初中到底哪里不好？
Kids there are all in socially awkward stages, that the drama every day can be frustrating. And girls write things that are someone likes so and so. And then no matter who you are, or what you do, you'll get made fun of for it. Anything, anything in the world you can get made fun of for.
那里的孩子都处在社交尴尬期，每天的戏码多到让人抓狂。女孩们会写一些关于某人喜欢谁谁谁的纸条。无论你是谁，或者你做什么，你都会因此被嘲笑。世界上任何事情，你都可能因此被嘲笑。
In Annie's case, she had friends who smoked, so she got criticized for smoking. But then she also was made fun of for not smoking, for being too much of a sissy to start smoking. She was made fun of for coming from a bilingual elementary school where everybody learned to speak Spanish and spoke it throughout the day.
就安妮的情况而言，她有朋友抽烟，所以她因为抽烟被批评。但她也因为不抽烟而被嘲笑，被说成是个没胆量开始抽烟的胆小鬼。她还因为来自一所双语小学而被嘲笑，在那种学校里，每个人都学西班牙语，并且整天用西班牙语交流。
And leaving elementary school, I guess I thought that when I got to middle school, everyone would think it was really cool that I spoke Spanish, but when I got there, they mostly just thought it was dumb. I don't know if they were jealous or what. They would make fun of me for it. Then they'd say we were all full of ourselves, that we spoke different languages and stuff.
离开小学时，我以为到了初中，大家会觉得我会说西班牙语特别酷，但当我到了那里，他们大多觉得这很蠢。我不知道他们是嫉妒还是怎么的。他们会因此嘲笑我。然后他们会说我们自以为是，说我们讲些乱七八糟的语言之类的。
Did it make you feel bad?
这让你觉得难受吗？
Yeah, I didn't want to stick out in that way. If I got a new sweater or something, say for Christmas, that I really liked, and I would really want to wear it to school or something, but I'd be nervous because what if someone didn't like my sweater or someone made fun of me for wearing it. It can be hard to do even the smallest things, because you're so nervous that people tease you or judge you from it.
是的，我不想那样格格不入。如果我有一件新毛衣，比如说圣诞节收到的，我很喜欢，我很想穿到学校，但我会很紧张，万一有人不喜欢我的毛衣，或者有人因为我穿它而嘲笑我怎么办。即使做最小的事情也很难，因为你太紧张了，怕人们因为这些而取笑或评判你。
That sweater example, is that a real example?
那个毛衣的例子，是真的吗？
Yeah, it actually is. I worried about it so much. I also had a pair of moccasins that I'd never worn, and they're kind of my signature now. Everybody really likes them. They're ankle-high, lace-up moccasins.
是的，确实是真的。我为此担心了很久。我还有一双从未穿过的莫卡辛鞋，现在它们算是我的标志了。大家都真的很喜欢它们。它们是脚踝高、系带的莫卡辛鞋。
And how long did you have the moccasins before you actually wore them?
那双鞋你放了多久才穿上？
A few months, probably two months. I guess I just thought if people didn't like them, they would all make fun of me for wearing them. And I didn't want to stand out that much.
几个月，大概两个月吧。我想我只是觉得如果人们不喜欢它们，他们会因为我穿它们而取笑我。我不想表现得那么引人注目。
What could be done to make middle school better?
有什么办法能让初中变得更好吗？
I don't think you can really do anything about it. [LAUGHS] Nothing.
我觉得你对此无能为力。[笑] 什么都做不了。
We talked about this for a little while. She said basically, everybody comes into middle school as a little kid, and you're going to have to grow up, and figure out who's in what group, and who you are, and who's above who. And you're going to have to figure that out somewhere at that age, right? It might as well be middle school. And it was terrible, she says, but now she's in high school.
我们聊了一会儿。她说基本上每个人进入初中时都是个小孩子，你必须长大，弄清楚谁在哪个圈子里，你是谁，谁比谁地位高。在那个年纪，你总得在某个地方弄明白这些，对吧？那不如就在初中吧。她说那段经历很糟糕，但现在她上高中了。
Whatever middle school was, it worked. Everyone is a lot friendlier, and everyone's lives are a lot better now.
不管初中是什么样的，它都起作用了。现在大家友好多了，每个人的生活也都好多了。
Well, today on our radio program, for Annie we look at whatever it is that happens in those mysterious years that we call middle school. We have stories today from all over the country, people lurching their way through these years when you're figuring out so, so much. We go to middle school dances and classrooms, and down to the Mexican border. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的广播节目中，为了安妮，我们将探究那些被称为“初中”的神秘岁月里到底发生了什么。今天我们有来自全国各地的故事，记录了人们在这些年里步履蹒跚地前行，而你在此期间会学到太多太多的东西。我们将走进初中的舞会和教室，一直到墨西哥边境。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Life in the Middle Ages. So we wanted to understand what is going on exactly physically and emotionally with middle school kids, and we talked to all kinds of people about that these last few weeks. And one of the producers on our staff had a very strong opinion about all this, Alex Blumberg. Before he got into radio, he taught in a middle school in Chicago for four years. He was a science teacher. And he concluded from that experience--
第一幕：中世纪的生活。所以我们想了解初中生在生理和心理上到底发生了什么，过去几周我们采访了各种各样的人。我们员工中的一位制作人亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格对此有非常强烈的看法。在进入广播行业之前，他在芝加哥的一所初中教了四年书。他曾是一名科学老师。他从那段经历中得出结论——
I don't know if they learned anything. They are so consumed with learning all these other lessons about where they fit in, in the social order, and how their bodies are now working and--
我不知道他们是否学到了什么。他们太沉迷于学习其他那些关于他们在社会阶层中处于什么位置、身体正在发生什么变化的课程，以及——
And who they're going to be.
以及他们将来会成为什么样的人。
--who they're attracted to, and who they're going to be, that facts and figures and geography, and all the other stuff that you teach in school, it just doesn't even penetrate.
——他们对谁感兴趣，他们将来会成为什么样的人，以至于事实、数字、地理以及你在学校教的所有其他东西，根本就进不去他们的脑子。
Wait, are you saying we shouldn't even bother to have them in school? We should just basically put them to work in the factory for two or three years?
等等，你是说我们甚至不应该费心让他们去上学？我们应该基本上让他们去工厂工作两三年吗？
Yeah. I basically came away thinking you're sort of wasting your time trying to teach middle school students anything.
是的。我基本上得出的结论是，试图教初中生任何东西都是在浪费时间。
If that seems just insane, Alex told me that Maria Montessori, who's the creator of the Montessori schools who looked at what kids could learn at each developmental stage, at one point in her career actually tossed out a similar suggestion. Perhaps, she said, young adolescents would be better off at a farm school, what she called an Erdkinder, where they would work with the land.
如果这听起来简直不可理喻，亚历克斯告诉我，蒙台梭利学校的创始人玛丽亚·蒙台梭利，她曾研究过孩子们在每个发育阶段能学到什么，她在职业生涯的某个阶段实际上提出了一个类似的建议。她说，也许青少年在农场学校会更好，她称之为“大地之子”（Erdkinder），在那里他们将与土地一起劳作。
[LAUGHING] Has he just got a great sense of humor or what?
[笑] 他是幽默感太强了还是怎么回事？
I ran Alex's thoughts by Marian Strok, the principle of Evergreen Academy Middle School in Chicago, which was listed as one of the best middle schools in the country, a school to watch, by the National Forum to Accelerate Middle Grades Reform.
我把亚历克斯的想法告诉了芝加哥常青学院初中的校长玛丽安·斯特罗克，该校被全国初中教育改革加速论坛列为全国最好的初中之一，是一所值得关注的学校。
I have to say, well, I obviously don't agree, OK? I think that we definitely have a way to stick knowledge in their heads. It's being creative about how we do it, and taking into consideration all of those other things. I'm not going to lie. It's not easy.
我不得不说，嗯，我显然不同意，好吗？我认为我们绝对有办法把知识塞进他们的脑子里。关键在于我们要以创造性的方式来做，并考虑到所有其他因素。我不会撒谎。这并不容易。
Can I ask you how much of the stereotype around students this age is true? Are you saying that the stereotype is true? You just have to deal with what it is?
我可以问问你，关于这个年龄段学生的成见有多少是真的吗？你是说这种成见是真实的吗？你只能去应对它吗？
It is true, and you have to-- as the adult in the situation-- you have to find a way to work around it, find a way to help them to grow up. They won't have to suffer if we do things right. They won't have to suffer as much, let's say. I mean you're going to go through emotional changes, and your body's changing. That can't be helped. The raging hormones, that can't be helped. All of that can't be helped. It's the way that we react to it that will make such a difference in their lives. It's our flexibility. It's our concern. It's our listening to them. It's our hearing them out.
这是真的，你必须——作为这种情况下的成年人——你必须找到一种方法来绕过它，找到一种方法来帮助他们成长。如果我们做得对，他们就不必受苦。或者说，他们不必受那么多苦。我的意思是，你必然会经历情感变化，你的身体在发生变化。这是不可避免的。荷尔蒙的激增，这是不可避免的。所有这些都是不可避免的。我们应对它的方式将会对他们的生活产生巨大的影响。关键在于我们的灵活性。在于我们的关心。在于我们倾听他们。在于我们听取他们的想法。
And so what's actually happening developmentally in the bodies and brains of kids when they're in middle school?
那么，当孩子们上初中时，他们的身体和大脑在发育上到底发生了什么？
Let me give the overview this way. The terrible 12s are a complete analog to the terrible twos. They're just not as cute, right?
让我这样来概述。12岁是个可怕的年纪，完全对应着“可怕的两岁”。只是他们没那么可爱了，对吧？
This is Linda Perlstein. When she wrote a book called Not Much, Just Chillin': The Hidden Lives of Middle Schoolers, following five middle school students very closely for a full year, she also incidentally researched everything she could find out about what is going on developmentally with kids that age that makes them so different from other ages. And it's fascinating.
这位是琳达·珀尔斯坦。当她写那本名为《不多，只是闲逛：初中生隐藏的生活》的书时，她非常密切地跟踪了五名初中生整整一年。顺便说一句，她还研究了关于那个年龄段孩子发育情况的所有资料，这使他们与其他年龄段的孩子如此不同。这非常迷人。
This is the time of biggest growth for a human being, aside from infancy. So your bones are growing faster than your muscles, so you can't actually sit still.
除了婴儿期，这是人类生长最快的时期。所以你的骨骼生长速度超过了肌肉，导致你根本无法静坐。
But your brain, your gray matter-- during the middle school years, what happens in your early stages of puberty is this fast overproduction of brain cells and connections, far more than you actually need. And only some of them are going to survive puberty. This growth in your frontal cortex, it peaks at 11 for girls and 12 for boys. And then what happens is the cells just fight it out for survival. And the ones that last are the ones you exercise more.
但是你的大脑，你的灰质——在初中几年里，青春期早期发生的是大脑细胞和连接的快速过量生产，远超你的实际需要。其中只有一部分能度过青春期。这种大脑前额皮质的生长，女孩在11岁、男孩在12岁达到顶峰。接下来发生的是，细胞为了生存而进行竞争。最后存活下来的，就是你锻炼得更多的那部分。
In other words, during those years, your brain turns you into you, the adult you. The stuff you don't exercise just kind of goes away. And what stays?
换句话说，在那几年里，你的大脑把你变成了现在的你，成年后的你。你没有锻炼到的东西就消失了。那么什么留下了呢？
So if you think about what you learned at the early stages of puberty, I don't know what that was for you. For me it was tap dancing and French. It sticks. I know French much better than any language I learned after that, and not because I had a better teacher. I was learning it at the right time. I can still do tap dances, though I won't, that I learned when I was 12 or 13.
所以，如果你回想一下你在青春期早期学到的东西——我不确定对你来说那是什么。对我来说是踢踏舞和法语。它留下来了。我掌握法语的程度远超我后来学的任何语言，这并不是因为我遇到了更好的老师。我是在正确的时间学习它的。尽管我不会跳了，但我还能跳出我在12或13岁时学的踢踏舞。
Yeah, I can still do magic tricks that I learned at that age.
是的，我还能表演我在那个年纪学的魔术。
Exactly, it's embossed in your existence. It's this important time for your brain. It's this use it or lose it time.
没错，它印在了你的生命里。这对你的大脑来说是一个重要的时期。这是一个“不用就废”的时期。
Linda Perlstein agrees that all the stereotypes about middle schoolers, everything, in fact, that Annie complained about, all of that is true. But she says that there's a flip side that people don't usually talk about. Middle school is when kids open up to the world. It's when they think about bigger things. And they haven't formed their opinions on things yet. Everything is up for grabs, which is amazing to be around.
琳达·珀尔斯坦同意关于初中生的所有刻板印象，事实上，安妮抱怨的所有事情都是真实的。但她说，人们通常不会谈论事情的另一面。初中是孩子们向世界敞开心扉的时候。这是他们思考更宏大事物的时候。而且他们还没有形成对事物的看法。一切皆有可能，这真的很棒。
I just think kids that age are fun. I like being around them. Middle schoolers are in that real nice spot of being interesting, but also being able to explain to you what's going on in their minds and why they do things they do. They're self-reflective. They're capable of self-reflection in a way that younger kids might not be.
我只是觉得那个年纪的孩子很有趣。我喜欢和他们在一起。初中生处于一个非常好的阶段，既有趣，又能向你解释他们脑子里在想什么以及为什么要那样做。他们善于反思。他们具备那种更小的孩子可能不具备的反思能力。
Older kids, she says, high school kids, by then they can be jaded or cynical. They're settling into who they are. In middle school, everything's new. You're probably picking your friends for the very first time.
她说，大一点的孩子，也就是高中生，到那时他们可能已经变得愤世嫉俗或冷嘲热讽了。他们正在定型。在初中，一切都是新鲜的。你可能第一次选择你的朋友。
For the first time, they aren't just the kids on your block or your parents' friends' kids, or the kids who are around. And so you make a best friend one day, who then you drop two weeks later. You get obsessed with guitar or computers or dance for two weeks, and then two weeks later, you drop it. For everything that's awful about middle school, she says, that's the great thing about it. You experiment.
这是第一次，他们不仅仅是你街坊邻居的孩子，或者是父母朋友的孩子，或者仅仅是周围的孩子。所以你今天交了一个最好的朋友，两周后又不理他了。你会在两周内痴迷于吉他、电脑或舞蹈，然后两周后又放弃了。她说，初中的所有可怕之处，正是它的伟大之处。你在实验。
Act Two, Stutter Steps. One good place to see the experiment that is life in middle school in action is a middle school dance. Last Friday, there were middle school dances all over the country, all at the same time, and we sent reporters to a half dozen of them to find out how kids were doing. They talked to them before the kids went inside to the field of battle. And, no surprise, we found a lot of stress, a lot of uncertainty.
第二幕：踉跄的脚步。观察初中生活实验的一个好地方是初中舞会。上周五，全国各地的初中都在同一时间举办舞会，我们派记者去了六个舞会现场，看看孩子们表现如何。他们在孩子们进入战场之前与他们进行了交谈。不出所料，我们发现了很多压力和不确定性。
Who's nervous about tonight?
谁对今晚感到紧张？
I am.
我。
Why?
为什么？
Well, just you don't know what's it going to be like. And I'm just confused. I just don't know. Yeah.
嗯，只是因为你不知道会发生什么。我真的很困惑。我就是不知道。是的。
These four girls are sixth graders, and they're in a car on the way to a neon-themed dance at Edgewood Middle School in Highland Park, Illinois, with their mom and reporter Rob Wildeboer.
这四个女孩是六年级学生，她们正和妈妈以及记者罗布·威尔德博尔坐车前往伊利诺伊州海兰帕克埃奇伍德初中的霓虹主题舞会。
Who's going to dance with a boy tonight?
今晚谁要和男生跳舞？
Nobody.
没人。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I can tell you that.
我可以告诉你。
No one in this car.
这车里没人。
Roughly 800 miles east in New Jersey, sixth grader Ethan Derose was hoping there would be at least one slow dance, though did he feel ready for a slow dance?
在大约800英里外的东部新泽西州，六年级学生伊桑·德罗斯希望至少能有一场慢舞，尽管他觉得自己准备好跳慢舞了吗？
Nope, not at all.
没有，完全没有。
Why not? What are you worried about?
为什么不呢？你担心什么？
I just don't know how to do it. I'm not sure that I'll do it correctly or-- yeah.
我就是不知道该怎么跳。我不确定我能不能跳对，或者——是的。
He's standing in front of the school with one of our producers, Brian Reed, as kids stream into the school. Ethan is wearing a button-up shirt with green and black stripes that he is not happy with.
他正和我们的制作人之一布莱恩·里德站在学校门前，看着孩子们涌入学校。伊桑穿着一件他不喜欢的绿黑条纹衬衫。
That was my mom. She made me wear it. She said that if I don't wear the two shirts that I am wearing right now that I can't go to the dance.
那是我的妈妈。是她逼我穿的。她说如果我不穿我现在身上这两件衬衫，我就不能去舞会。
What are you hoping happens at this dance?
你希望在这个舞会上发生什么？
I'm hoping nothing bad happens, like no humiliation or not something that'll be a story for the next month or two.
我希望什么坏事都别发生，比如没有羞辱，或者不是那种会成为未来一两个月谈资的事情。
Of course, Ethan and the girls in that car in Illinois are sixth graders. In New York City, seventh graders Evelyn Benson and Alice Westerman are excited and feeling very grown up on their way to their school's Halloween dance.
当然，伊桑和伊利诺伊州车里的女孩们都是六年级学生。在纽约市，七年级学生伊芙琳·本森和爱丽丝·韦斯特曼正兴奋地前往学校的万圣节舞会，感觉自己很成熟。
I'm really happy because last year, they split the gym in half, so it's light on one side and pitch black on the other side. All the sixth graders are banned from the dark side, but that's where all the cool kids are. So now we're in seventh grade, we can dance on the dark side. So it's like, woo, we're cool.
我真的很开心，因为去年他们把体育馆一分为二，所以一边亮着，另一边漆黑一片。所有六年级学生都被禁止进入黑暗区，但酷孩子们都在那里。所以现在我们上七年级了，我们可以在黑暗区跳舞了。所以感觉就是，呜呼，我们很酷。
Dance on the dark side.
在黑暗区跳舞。
Some of the middle school boys got up the nerve to ask girls to be their dates to the dances. But because this is a new experience for the girls too, being asked out on a date, they don't exactly know how to handle it. Here's a girl named Autumn talking with our producer, Lisa Pollak, in Delaware, the afternoon of the dance.
一些初中男生鼓起勇气邀请女孩做舞伴。但因为这对女孩来说也是一种新体验，被邀请约会，她们并不太清楚如何处理。这位叫奥特姆的女孩在舞会当天的下午和我们的制作人丽莎·波拉克在特拉华州进行了交谈。
Did you get asked to the dance?
有人邀请你去舞会了吗？
Yes, I did.
是的，有了。
And what did you say?
你说了什么？
I said I don't know, but I probably won't say yes.
我说我不知道，但我可能不会答应。
Wait, you haven't told him yes or no yet?
等等，你还没告诉他答应还是拒绝？
No.
没有。
OK, so it's 1:20, and the dance is at 7:00.
好吧，现在是下午1点20分，舞会是7点。
Yeah.
是的。
When do you have to let him know?
你什么时候必须告诉他？
I probably won't answer.
我可能不会回答。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
Yeah. I just kind of want to hang out with the girls.
是的。我只是想和女孩们待在一起。
So he's the only one who asked you.
所以他是唯一一个邀请你的人？
There was other people too.
还有其他人。
How many?
多少人？
Probably five-ish.
大概五个左右吧。
Five boys asked you to the dance?
五个男生邀请你去舞会？
Yeah.
是的。
You told all these guys, I don't know?
你告诉所有这些人“我不知道”？
Yeah.
是的。
What if they took that as a yes?
如果他们把这当作是答应了怎么办？
Then they got the wrong answer.
那他们就理解错了。
Do you say "I don't know" because it feels too mean to say no?
你说“我不知道”是因为直接拒绝显得太刻薄了吗？
Yeah, I'm not mean.
是的，我不刻薄。
Of course, some of the boys are no better. During the dance in Windham, Maine, our reporter Claire Holman pulled six grader, Christopher Potter, out of the action for a chat.
当然，有些男生也好不到哪去。在缅因州温德姆的舞会上，我们的记者克莱尔·霍尔曼把六年级学生克里斯托弗·波特从活动中拉出来聊了聊。
Is there anyone you like at the dance?
舞会有你喜欢的女孩吗？
There is.
有。
Does she know?
她知道吗？
Yes, she does. We're kind of dating at the time.
是的，她知道。我们当时算是正在约会。
So how's that going?
那进展如何？
Good, it just started 20 minutes into this, so yeah.
很好，刚开始20分钟，所以，是的。
You asked a girl to go out during the dance?
你在舞会期间邀请了一个女孩约会？
No, a girl came to me and asked me out.
不，是一个女孩过来邀请我约会。
OK, let's go over it minute by minute. So where were you when this happened?
好吧，让我们一分钟一分钟地回顾一下。这事发生时你在哪？
I was in the cafeteria, just got a drink of root beer, and she walks up to me and asks me to go out.
我在食堂，刚买了一杯根汁汽水，她走过来邀请我约会。
What did she say exactly?
她具体说了什么？
She said, "Chris, will you go out with me?"
她说：“克里斯，你愿意跟我约会吗？”
And were you surprised?
你感到惊讶吗？
Not really. We've kind of been on and off again.
没怎么有。我们算是那种分分合合的关系。
So it's not the first time.
所以这不是第一次了。
Yeah, not the first time.
是的，不是第一次。
But she always asks you? Or do you ever ask her?
但总是她邀请你吗？或者你有没有邀请过她？
Well, it's kind of weird, because it's always, she wants me to ask her. So it was weird that she asked me.
嗯，这有点奇怪，因为一直以来，都是她希望我邀请她。所以她主动邀请我挺奇怪的。
Usually, they don't last. It's a middle school relationship. Nothing really happens.
通常，这些关系都维持不长。这是初中生的恋爱。其实什么都不会发生。
What does that mean, a middle school relationship? What do you mean  it doesn't last?
那是什么意思，“初中生的恋爱”？你指的维持不长是什么意思？
It's destined to fail pretty much.
基本上注定要失败。
Yeah, because it's a middle school. This isn't where you're starting your life with. You don't hear things about middle school sweethearts.
是的，因为那是初中。这不是你要开始一生的那种对象。你很少听说什么“初中恋人”。
In Richmond, outside Moody Middle School's dance, reporter Eric Mennel spoke with Elliot German and his step-brother Jonathan Lawton. They're both eighth graders who ran through the official rules for the dance.
在里士满，穆迪初中舞会外，记者埃里克·门内尔采访了艾略特·日耳曼和他的继兄弟乔纳森·劳顿。他们都是八年级学生，谈到了舞会的官方规定。
So some of them are kind of funny, because I mean it's like no hands below the waist, no petting, which I thought was kind of funny.
其中一些规则挺逗的，因为我的意思是，比如腰部以下不能有手，不能有爱抚行为，我觉得这挺搞笑的。
Wait, no petting?
等等，不能有爱抚行为？
Yeah, no petting.
是的，不能。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
No one knows.
没人知道。
It was specifically on the flier that they hand out. They give you the dress code, and then they give you the rules, "no petting." And it's in quotations, and you never know what it means. Do people sit there at dances and just pet other people? Because that would be really weird.
这是专门印在他们发的传单上的。他们给你着装要求，然后给你规则：“不能有爱抚行为”。而且是加了引号的，你永远不知道它意味着什么。难道真的有人在舞会上坐着就互相爱抚吗？因为那会非常奇怪。
There are rules like this at all the dances, and some more comprehensible than others. As for whether or not the kids obey the rules and what actually happens inside the dance on the actual dance floor, one of our producers, Lisa Pollak, went inside to the dance floor at the Fall Costume dance in Lewes, Delaware. And I'm going to hand it off to her.
所有舞会上都有这样的规则，有些规则比其他规则更容易理解。至于孩子们是否遵守规则，以及舞会内舞池里到底发生了什么，我们的制作人丽莎·波拉克进入了特拉华州刘易斯的秋季化装舞会现场。我要把接力棒交给她。
So the scene in the gym was pretty much the way you remember it. Older kids dancing in the middle, younger kids at the periphery, a few aimlessly wandering around, looking like they're not sure what to do. Lots of kids were dancing, jumping up and down. Occasionally, you'd see a fist pump. They danced in these tightly packed clusters, very little room between them. And outside of the clusters were chaperons, ready to step in if they saw any grinding or suggestive dancing.
所以体育馆里的场景和你记忆中差不多。大孩子在中间跳舞，小的在边缘，少数几个漫无目的地游荡，看起来不太确定该做什么。很多孩子在跳舞，上下跳跃。偶尔你会看到一个挥拳动作。他们挤成一团紧密地跳舞，中间几乎没有空间。在人群外围是监督老师，一旦看到任何磨蹭或暧昧的舞蹈，他们就会随时介入。
Hovering outside one of the clusters was a teacher named John Gauze, and he looked perplexed.
一个叫约翰·高兹的老师徘徊在人群外，他看起来很困惑。
This knot has got me on edge at this point.
这个结此刻让我很紧张。
Why?
为什么？
Because they're trying to get away with stuff. You can tell by the way they're looking at you. They have a guilty look, because you're about to see me swoop.
因为他们试图做些越界的事。你可以从他们的眼神中看出来。他们有一种内疚感，因为你即将看到我冲进去。
He actually did swoop. He plunged into the pack of kids, pulled the boy aside and talked to him. Then he told me why.
他确实冲进去了。他闯入孩子们的人群中，把那个男孩拉到一边和他谈话。然后他告诉了我原因。
He needed to be taken aside and told to stop being up against those girls like that. I don't want to jump in too much, but I just want to give them the "whoa," the flat hand "whoa," just whoa. Just calm it down a little. I mean usually, if I see it, then they're going to stop because they see me.
他需要被带到一边，被告知不要那样紧贴着那些女孩。我不想干预太多，我只是想给他们一个“嘘”的手势，用平坦的手掌示意，就只是那样。稍微冷静点。我的意思是，通常如果我看到了，他们就会停下来，因为他们看到了我。
And then comes the moment of truth, the moment that forces every kid in the room to make a decision, the moment that separates the timid from the brave, the slow song. I watch it with teacher Brian Comra.
然后是关键时刻，那一刻迫使房间里的每个孩子做出决定，那一刻将胆怯与勇敢区分开来——慢歌。我和布莱恩·科姆拉老师一起看着。
So we got our slow song, and just as I suspected, a majority of the students left the dance floor. All the couples are in the middle of the dance floor in a cluster. I suspect so they're not near an adult.
我们听到了慢歌，正如我所料，大多数学生离开了舞池。所有的情侣都在舞池中央挤成一团。我想是因为这样离成年人远一点。
I love how the kids go up to the couples dancing and interrupt them.
我喜欢孩子们走到跳舞的情侣中间打断他们。
Oh absolutely.
噢，当然。
Some of the couples didn't have much privacy. Their friends were standing a foot away, hanging out and talking to them. And every so often, a random kid would just cut across the dance floor.
有些情侣没有多少隐私。朋友们就站在一英尺远的地方闲聊。每隔一会儿，就会有一个随机的孩子穿过舞池。
This girl right here just grabbed onto the back of her friend's neck while the friend was dancing with the boy.
那个女孩刚才抓住了她朋友的脖子后面，而那个朋友正在和一个男孩跳舞。
Yeah, I don't know if she didn't want to be left out, or they came as friends. I think at this stage of the game, it's hard when boys and girls pair off, and then one friend is always left behind.
是的，我不知道她是不是不想被落下，或者她们是一起作为朋友来的。我认为在这个阶段，当男孩女孩配对时，如果一个朋友总是被剩下，这很难受。
There are a few of these slow dances, but most of the songs are fast. And then suddenly, the song, "Hit the Road Jack" starts playing, and the lights snap on.
这里有几首慢歌，但大多数歌曲都是快节奏的。然后突然间，《Hit the Road Jack》开始播放，灯光亮起。
Oh my god, they just all like-- oh my god.
天哪，他们都……天哪。
Yeah, it ends very abruptly. It's 9:00. It's 9 o'clock.
是的，结束得非常突然。9点了。已经是9点了。
That's it?
就这样？
That's it. There's no wind down. 9 o'clock. Lights come on. Parents are waiting. It'll be empty in another minute.
就这样。没有缓冲。9点整。灯光亮起。家长们在等着。再过一分钟这里就空了。
And he was right. The experiment in mini-adulthood that is the middle school dance was over. The same kids who, minutes earlier, were holding each other and swaying awkwardly on the dance floor, got into cars and said hi to their parents.
他是对的。作为初中舞会的“准成人”实验结束了。几分钟前还在舞池里尴尬地互相拥抱和摇摆的同一个孩子，坐进车里，向父母问好。
Lisa Pollak. Coming up, surviving middle school by pretending that you are from a completely different family. That is in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
丽莎·波拉克。接下来，通过假装你来自一个完全不同的家庭来幸存初中。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show of course we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，带来关于这个主题的不同故事。
Today's show, Middle School. A 14-year-old from California who just got out of middle school asked for a show on the horror that is middle school.
今天的节目主题是“初中”。一位刚离开初中的加州14岁孩子要求制作一期关于初中恐怖经历的节目。
It'd be cool to like hear other people's stories about it and what they went through.
能听听别人的故事和他们经历过什么，那该多酷啊。
We thought, you know, that's a pretty good idea. That is a place with a lot of stories. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Mimis in the Middle. The place that Domingo Martinez went to middle school, they still called it junior high. And he says that his sisters did something to cope with any feelings of inferiority they might have otherwise felt in their new school with all those new kids.
我们想，你知道，这是个不错的主意。那是个有很多故事的地方。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕：中间的咪咪。多明戈·马丁内斯上初中的那个地方，他们仍然称之为“初中”（Junior High）。他说他的姐妹们为了应付在新学校面对那些新孩子可能感到的任何自卑感，做了一件事。
When they started junior high, my sisters, Mary and Margie, invented the Mimis. They were entering the sinister world of teenage girls, which in the mid 1980s in Brownsville, Texas, was tinged with border town racism. Instead of being ashamed of who they were, my sisters decided to create a polite fiction and invited everyone to participate.
当她们进入初中时，我的姐妹玛丽和玛吉发明了“咪咪”。她们进入了十几岁女孩的邪恶世界，在1980年代中期的德克萨斯州布朗斯维尔，这个世界里充满了边境小镇的种族主义。我的姐妹们决定创造一个礼貌的虚构，而不是为自己的身份感到羞耻，并邀请每个人参与其中。
First they died their brown-black hair blond until it turned the color and brittleness of hay. Then, they began dressing in Sergio Valente and Gloria Vanderbilt. And finally, to cap it off, they decided to call each other simply Mimi. A typical conversation between them went like this. "Mimi, do you like my new Jordache jeans?" "Yes Mimi, I do." "Do I look rich in my new Nike's Mimi?" "Mimi, you look like a tennis player, Mimi." "I know Mimi. Maybe I should make Mom buy me a racket."
首先，她们把棕黑色的头发染成金色，直到它变得像干草一样干枯发脆。然后，她们开始穿塞尔吉奥·瓦伦特和格洛丽亚·范德比尔特的品牌衣服。最后，为了画龙点睛，她们决定简单地称呼对方为“咪咪”。她们之间典型的对话是这样的：“咪咪，你喜欢我的新乔达什牛仔裤吗？”“是的，咪咪，我喜欢。”“我穿新耐克鞋看起来很有钱吗，咪咪？”“咪咪，你看起来像个网球选手，咪咪。”“我知道，咪咪。也许我应该让妈妈给我买个球拍。”
It was really that simple. The Mimis made a conscious decision that they would be rich and white, even if their family wasn't. In other words, Marge and Mary had a small break from reality that we all participated in to help them through junior high. We all helped in creating the Mimis.
事情真的就这么简单。咪咪们做出了一个自觉的决定，即使家里没钱，她们也要做一个有钱的白人。换句话说，玛吉和玛丽经历了一次小小的现实崩溃，我们所有人都参与其中，帮助她们度过初中。我们所有人都帮忙创造了“咪咪”。
At the time, the rest of the family had not fully realized that our job, as relatively new Americans and, worse yet Texans, was to be as white as possible. And we honestly didn't see their delusion as anything other than another bewildering tactic in our sisters' quest for a higher level of superior fashion. Just teenage girls doing what teenage girls do.
当时，家里其余的人还没有完全意识到，作为相对较新的美国人，更糟糕的是德州人，我们的工作就是尽可能显得像白人。我们老实说，没把她们的错觉看作是除了她们姐妹对更高层次的优越时尚追求之外的任何其他令人困惑的策略。只是十几岁的女孩在做十几岁女孩会做的事情。
There had been a time when our family had been rich by barrio standards because our grandpa, dad's stepfather, fought in the Korean War and used his GI money to start a trucking business when he got back. He married grandma, who was widowed from her first marriage at age 16, and gave both her and my dad citizenship.
曾经有一段时间，以社区的标准来看，我们家是很富有的，因为我的祖父，爸爸的继父，参加过朝鲜战争，并在回国后用他的退伍军人津贴开了一家货运公司。他娶了祖母，祖母在16岁时就从第一次婚姻中守寡，他给了她和爸爸公民身份。
My siblings and I, we were all born in Brownsville as Americans, but really didn't understand what that meant. Then grandpa died in 1980, and our world began to crumble. The trucking business began to disintegrate around dad, and he was started on his slow road towards desperation and religion. Meanwhile, the Mimis had made their decision to be two, blue-blooded, trust-funded, tennis buddies from Connecticut accidentally living in Brownsville, Texas, with us, a poor Mexican family they had somehow befriended while undergoing some Dickensian series of misfortunes.
我和我的兄弟姐妹都是在布朗斯维尔出生的美国人，但并没有真正理解这意味着什么。然后祖父在1980年去世了，我们的世界开始崩溃。货运公司开始在爸爸身边解体，他开始了通往绝望和宗教的缓慢道路。与此同时，咪咪们决定成为两个来自康涅狄格州的、蓝血的、拥有信托基金的、网球伙伴，偶然生活在德克萨斯州布朗斯维尔的我们这些贫穷的墨西哥家庭中，她们不知何故通过一系列狄更斯式的挫折与我们结缘。
No one acted like it was peculiar, especially those in the family who didn't speak English or could not understand the Mimis when they showed up at family gatherings. [SPEAKING SPANISH], one of the Mimis would say to an uncle or cousin, who more often than not would linger lasciviously around them, at first conflicted by the idea of being turned on by so young a relative. And then mentally calculating just how distantly related they were and tabulating his odds of scoring with this new white chick who just happened to show up at this barrio party.
没有人表现得觉得这很奇怪，特别是家里那些不会说英语或听不懂咪咪们在家庭聚会上说什么的人。“[西班牙语]”，其中一个咪咪会对叔叔或堂兄弟说，后者通常会好色地徘徊在她们身边，起初因为被如此年轻的亲戚吸引而感到纠结，然后心里盘算着他们之间的血缘关系有多远，并计算着和这个刚出现在社区派对上的新白人女孩搭讪的几率。
"Mimi, how did you like my Spanish?"
“咪咪，你觉得我的西班牙语怎么样？”
"Oh Mimi, it's getting really good."
“噢，咪咪，越来越好了。”
"Mimi, do you think they understood me?"
“咪咪，你觉得他们听懂我了吗？”
"Oh Mimi, who cares?"
“噢，咪咪，谁在乎呢？”
Soon, the Mimis were buzzing at a fever pitch, intoxicating everyone who came near and cut a whiff of the Mimis' Anais Anais perfume. We had all seen the commercials on network television while watching Dallas or Knots Landing . And it was a forbidden fragrance for rain depressed English women with secret, muscular boyfriends who drove Jaguars dangerously through unpaved, one-laned Scottish roads. So the Mimis had to have it, and they found it at the local JC Penney and had Mom pay for it.
很快，咪咪们就在狂热的高潮中嗡嗡作响，让任何靠近并闻到咪咪们身上雅娜雅娜（Anais Anais）香水味的人都沉醉其中。我们都在电视上看过网络广告，当时正在看《达拉斯》或《诺兹兰丁》。那对于正处于绝望中的、有秘密肌肉男友且开着捷豹危险地行驶在未铺设单车道苏格兰路上的英国女人来说，是一种禁忌的芬芳。所以咪咪们一定要拥有它，她们在当地的杰西潘尼百货商店找到了它，并让妈妈付了钱。
Me and my brother Dan, and our older sister Sylvia, we just kind of stank from the heat and dealt with it. Even Mom developed her own fascination with the Mimis, like she couldn't believe her luck now that she was related to royalty. So she was always ready for an air-conditioned trip to the mall. She took the little clothes budget reserved for us boys, my brother and me, and added it into the Mimis' wardrobe because to her, it was a sign of status for the family that the Mimis looked their best. None of the rest of us would question it, even though it felt wrong.
我和哥哥丹，还有姐姐西尔维娅，我们就只是因为炎热而感到难受，忍受着。甚至妈妈也对咪咪们产生了她自己的迷恋，好像她不敢相信自己的好运，现在她成了皇室亲戚。所以她总是准备好去商场享受冷气。她拿走了留给我们男孩的服装预算，给咪咪们增加了衣柜，因为对她来说，咪咪们打扮得漂漂亮亮是家庭地位的象征。我们其余的人都没人提出质疑，即使这感觉不对。
I was often left with the Mimis' recently stylish hand-me-downs. No one else in my grade school was remotely label conscious or capable of reading in English really, so it passed unnoticed that most of my clothes were made for glamorous, junior high school girls. Almost every child at my school came from recently immigrated families, kids so poor they'd save half their free lunch to share with their younger siblings at home, their heads shaved to rid them of lice.
我经常被留给咪咪们那些刚过时但依然时髦的旧衣服。我的小学里没人在意品牌，也没人能真正读懂英语，所以大部分衣服都是为迷人的初中女孩制作的这一事实也没被察觉。我学校里的几乎每个孩子都来自新移民家庭，孩子们穷到甚至会攒下一半的免费午餐分给家里的弟弟妹妹，为了除掉虱子把头剃得精光。
My best friend, Arthur, he noticed though. He was part black and part Mexican, had just moved to Brownsville from some big city slum in Michigan where his mother's boyfriend had been employed at a GM factory, and he read labels. "Hey Dom," he said, "yo man. You're wearing a girl's shirt. Or is Esprit making baggy boy's shirts now too?" So to change the subject, I slugged him high in the chest and ran away. He chased me down to punch me back, and left me crying in my girl's blouse.
但我的好朋友阿瑟注意到了。他是黑人和墨西哥混血，刚从密歇根州的一个大城市贫民窟搬到布朗斯维尔，他母亲的男朋友曾在通用汽车工厂工作，他认得品牌。“嘿，多姆，”他说，“伙计。你穿着女孩的衬衫。还是埃斯普利特（Esprit）现在也做宽松的男式衬衫了？”为了转移话题，我朝他的胸口狠狠打了一拳然后跑开了。他追上来打我，留下我穿着女孩的衬衫在那哭。
If she had any guilt about giving the Mimis the lion's share of the clothing budget, I imagine the justification my mother probably used was that my older brother and I would just ruin our clothes working with Dad under the greasy trucks. It made better sense for the Mimis to be in high fashion than for the feral boys to wreck new clothes.
如果她在给咪咪们大部分服装预算方面有任何内疚，我想我母亲可能用的理由是，我和哥哥在爸爸那些油腻的卡车下干活会弄坏衣服。比起让野孩子弄坏新衣服，让咪咪们穿得时髦更有道理。
"Mimi, you look just like Jennifer Beals in Flashdance. You should join the dance team at school." "I know Mimi. I think so too." "Mimi, I think you should dye your hair back to its original color, ash." "I know Mimi. I'm trying."
“咪咪，你看起来就像《闪舞》里的詹妮弗·比尔斯。你应该加入学校的舞蹈队。”“我知道，咪咪。我也这么觉得。”“咪咪，我觉得你应该把头发染回原来的颜色，灰褐色。”“我知道，咪咪。我正在努力。”
During this time, my brother Dan's eyesight was so bad he couldn't read the blackboard in school and constantly ran into corners or short skinny people. People thought he was Asian he squinted so much. Every photo of him taken in junior high, he looks like he's trying to see into the photographer's eyes through the camera lens. This of course goes entirely unnoticed, and it is the younger Mimi, Mary with the 20-20 vision, who gets vanity glasses with her name etched in gold script in the corner. Dan wouldn't get classes until he was in the military when he was 17.
在这段时间里，哥哥丹的视力太差了，他在学校里看不见黑板，经常撞到墙角或个子矮瘦的人。人们以为他是亚洲人，因为他眯眼眯得太厉害了。每一张他在初中时拍的照片，他看起来都像是在试图透过相机镜头看摄影师的眼睛。这当然完全被忽略了，而且是视力极佳的年轻咪咪玛丽，得到了刻着她金色手写名字的虚荣眼镜。丹直到17岁入伍时才配上眼镜。
Eventually, Dad's failure at navigating the business and providing for his family intruded on the Mimis' fantasy. Dad made a decision that as soon as school ended, Mom would take the Mimis and Sil, and drive them to California to participate in the seasonal grape harvest with Dad's cousins, people vaguely related to grandma through marriage, I think. They would be treated like adults there, paid the same as everyone else.
最终，爸爸在经营业务和养家糊口方面的失败侵入了咪咪们的幻想。爸爸决定，学校一放假，妈妈就带着咪咪们和西尔，开车送她们去加州参加季节性的葡萄采摘，那是爸爸通过婚姻与祖母有点亲戚关系的人，我想。在那里，她们会被当作成年人对待，报酬和别人一样。
Mom, I remember, was horrified at the implications, at the shame of having to send her virginal and royal daughters out to the fields. Plus, Dad's extended family out in California were very different from us, wild and frightening and Californian. Texas Mexicans and California Mexicans are very different from each other, like the Scottish and the Irish. The Mimis, though, were undaunted, did not understand the complications. "Mimi, we're going to California?" "Oh my god Mimi. We're going to be Valley girls." "Mimi, gag me with a spoon Mimi." "Mimi, your roots are showing." We packed up Mom, the Mimis, and Silvia in the beige, 1980 Pontiac Bonneville, already an antique on its second engine and failing transmission. And they drove out of Brownsville.
我记得妈妈对这些影响感到震惊，对不得不把她纯洁且皇室的女儿们送到田里感到羞耻。而且，爸爸在加州的大家族和我们很不一样，狂野、可怕且是加州式的。德州墨西哥人和加州墨西哥人非常不同，就像苏格兰人和爱尔兰人。然而咪咪们并没有被吓倒，不理解其中的复杂性。“咪咪，我们要去加州了吗？”“噢天哪，咪咪。我们要成为山谷女孩了。”“咪咪，用勺子堵住我的嘴，咪咪。”“咪咪，你的发根露出来了。”我们收拾好妈妈、咪咪们和西尔维娅，坐进那辆米色的1980年款庞蒂亚克博纳维尔，那是一辆引擎已经报废、变速箱正在故障的古董车。她们开车驶出了布朗斯维尔。
A year later, I took this ride as well, and also ended up picking grapes for the summer. That we were migrant workers for that period didn't occur to me, nor to anyone else. That label would never stick, could never stick. We couldn't descend to that level. We just had to do it to help out Dad. That was all. But it was too much for the Mimis, the reality of this first trip.
一年后，我也踏上了这趟旅程，最终也度过了一个夏天采摘葡萄。我们在那期间是迁徙劳工的事实，并没有出现在我的脑海里，也没有出现在任何人的脑海里。那个标签永远不会贴上，也不可能贴上。我们不能下降到那个水平。我们只是为了帮助爸爸才做这件事。就是这样。但这对咪咪们来说太过分了，这次旅行的现实。
Sadly, I think it was childhood's end for the Mimis. The vineyards had somehow inverted their secret garden, and the low door in the wall had closed shut behind them. When they first reached California, the Mimis did indeed become Valley girls, the hippest, cutest, best dressed migrant workers of that year, and very likely for many years to come.
可悲的是，我想这对咪咪们来说是童年的终结。葡萄园不知何故颠倒了她们的秘密花园，墙上的低矮门在她们身后紧闭。当她们第一次到达加州时，咪咪们确实成了山谷女孩，那一年度、甚至很可能在未来许多年里最时髦、最可爱、穿着最好的迁徙劳工。
The older Mimi, Marge, continued to dress like Jennifer Beals in Flashdance out in the fields, where the sun sizzled any inch of exposed skin. She wore a spaghetti-strapped, red and white striped Esprit top, white cotton shorts, and a matching headband with her red and white, leather Nike tennis shoes and took pictures of the vineyards and the workers with her Canon AE-1.
大一点的咪咪玛吉，继续在太阳灼伤每一寸暴露皮肤的田里打扮得像《闪舞》里的詹妮弗·比尔斯。她穿着吊带红白条纹埃斯普利特上衣、白色棉质短裤，戴着配套的发带，穿着红白相间的耐克网球鞋，用她的佳能AE-1相机给葡萄园和工人们拍照。
Eventually though, even she started dressing like the rest of the migrant workers, wearing long-sleeved collared shirts buttoned all the way to the neck, thick un-stylish denim and work boots, with a bandanna covering her nose and mouth, or else she would have died of heat stroke. There were no photos taken of that.
最终，即使是她也开始像其他迁徙劳工一样打扮，穿着扣到脖子上的长袖领衬衫，厚实且不时髦的牛仔裤和工作靴，用头巾遮住鼻子和嘴，否则她会死于热射病。没有留下照片。
Mary, the younger Mimi, did not fare any better. Her vanity glasses with the fake lenses were scratched well beyond recovery. Her roots grew out, and her hair turned a lighter brown as a result of the heat and the pesticides of the grape fields of southern California. The hard work went on all summer, and eventually it became bitter enough to breach even the walls of the Mimis' perfectly constructed fantasy.
年轻的咪咪玛丽也没有好到哪去。她那副带有假镜片的虚荣眼镜被划伤得无法修复。她的发根长了出来，因为南加州葡萄园的酷热和杀虫剂，她的头发变成了浅棕色。繁重的工作持续了整个夏天，最终变得苦涩到足以突破咪咪们精心构筑的幻想壁垒。
And so sadly, eventually even they were humiliated, and the illusion of wealth that had kept the family's idea of itself buoyant was deflated. When they returned to Brownsville, as happy as we were to see them, no one ever mentioned the Mimis again. They were gone, and it was Marge and Mary that returned in their place. Mary rubbing her nose with the palm of her hand from allergies, and snapping at anyone who tried to talk to her. And Marge, who never went back to California, and took a job at the bank the following summer instead.
所以可悲的是，最终连她们也受到了羞辱，那个让家庭维持自我认同感的财富幻想破灭了。当她们回到布朗斯维尔时，虽然我们很高兴见到她们，但再也没有人提起过“咪咪”了。她们消失了，取而代之的是玛吉和玛丽。玛丽因为过敏用手心擦着鼻子，对任何试图跟她说话的人发火。而玛吉，再也没有回过加州，第二年夏天在银行找了份工作。
I was sorry to see the Mimis go. We all were. When they were at their peak, the Mimis had been capable of creating a real sort of magic around them, enchanting both people and places so that you could be looking at the same dreary landscape as them, the same terrible and hopeless event. And while you might be miserable and bitter, they would be beaming, enthralled, and enthusiastically hopeful. And then, if you got near them, or were blessed enough to maybe talk to them, you would walk away feeling the same way as they felt too.
我很遗憾看到咪咪们的离去。我们所有人都是。当她们处于巅峰状态时，咪咪们能够围绕着她们创造出一种真正的魔力，让人物和地点都变得迷人，以至于你可以看着和她们同样的凄凉景色，同样可怕和绝望的事件。而当你可能感到痛苦和苦涩时，她们却会容光焕发、着迷且充满热情地怀抱希望。然后，如果你靠近她们，或者有幸能跟她们说上话，你走开时也会感觉到和她们一样的感觉。
They were a gift to everyone who was lucky enough to get caught in their Anais Anais, the Mimis. They made all of us Americans.
她们是送给所有有幸被困在她们的雅娜雅娜香水味中的人的礼物，那群咪咪们。她们让我们所有人都成了美国人。
Domingo Martinez, reading an excerpt from his memoir, The Boy Kings of Texas , which is going to be published by Lyons Press next July.
多明戈·马丁内斯，阅读他回忆录《德克萨斯的男孩国王》的节选，该书将于明年7月由里昂出版社出版。
Act Four, Anchor Babies. So this week as we were putting together the radio show and sending reporters out into middle schools, we discovered that in schools all over the country, there already were reporters on the ground, deep inside, covering the issues that middle school kids really care about.
第四幕：锚婴。所以这一周，当我们在制作广播节目并派记者进入初中时，我们发现全国各地的学校里早已有记者在实地工作，深入内部，报道初中生真正关心的议题。
Good afternoon Huskies. It is Thursday, September 15, 2011. After today, there are only 162 school days until summer vacation. I'm Taylor.
下午好，哈士奇队。今天是2011年9月15日，星期四。今天是放假前的第162个上学日。我是泰勒。
These are student newscasters from Hart Middle School in Pleasanton, California. I myself got my start on the mic on the morning announcements. And this is what middle school morning announcements in some schools are like today. Students make these full blown video productions. Some of them have music themes. [MUSIC PLAYING] The kids stand in front of banners with their school logo, or sometimes it's a green screen backdrop so they make it look like they're on a local TV news set.
这些是来自加利福尼亚州普莱森顿哈特初中的学生新闻主播。我自己就是在早间播报时开始话筒生涯的。这就是今天一些学校的初中早间播报的样子。学生们制作这些完整的视频作品。其中一些有音乐主题。[音乐播放] 孩子们站在印有校徽的横幅前，或者有时是绿屏背景，所以他们让画面看起来像是当地的新闻演播室。
Our producer Jonathan Menjivar has been watching these newscasts all week with fascination. And he has noticed a few trends.
我们的制作人乔纳森·门吉瓦尔这一周一直着迷地观看这些新闻播报。他注意到了一些趋势。
Just like the local news, middle school newscasts tend to follow a formula. They almost all start with the pledge of allegiance.
就像当地新闻一样，初中新闻播报往往遵循一种模式。它们几乎都以宣誓效忠开始。
--and to the republic.
——向共和国效忠。
This next segment from DMS News at Dibble Middle School in Dibble, Oklahoma, is a staple of almost every broadcast I watched.
接下来这段来自俄克拉荷马州迪布尔初中DMS新闻的片段，是我观看的几乎每个播报中的主要内容。
OK, we have late breaking news. You will be the first to know that we have two birthdays today. Happy birthday to both Gabriel Ramiro and Nathan Neidell.
好的，我们有最新突发新闻。你们将是第一批知道的人，今天有两位寿星。祝加布里埃尔·拉米罗和内森·尼德尔生日快乐。
This has to qualify as breaking news because it's school. There's not a lot of exciting stuff for them to report. They have to tell their fellow students what the cafeteria is serving that day, when make-up pictures are being taken, and do the weather. My favorite comes from this girl, McKenna, near Buffalo, who's clearly had enough.
这一定得算突发新闻，因为这是在学校。他们能报道的令人兴奋的事情不多。他们必须告诉同学当天食堂供应什么，什么时候拍补拍照片，以及天气情况。我最喜欢的是来自布法罗附近的一个叫麦肯纳的女孩，她显然已经受够了。
Good morning [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Middle School. This is McKenna with today's weather. It's going to be how it is, like it is now, pretty much all day. In the afternoon, colder, windy, and wet with heavier rain. [SIGHS] In the evening, winds to the southwest--
早上好，[无法辨认]初中。我是麦肯纳，播报今天的天气。今天的天气大概会和现在一样，基本上持续一整天。下午会变冷、有风且潮湿，伴有更大的雨。[叹气] 晚上，风吹向西南——
These newscasts are middle school in relief, like what you'd see if there was a middle school exhibit at the Natural History Museum. There are tiny kids with big ears, shy red-faced kids, jocks, computer club kids-- completely normal, super sweet, over-achieving ones. And spazzy kids, who are far too proud of their terrible jokes. They were fun to watch. I'd forgotten that middle school kids can have this over-confident goofiness.
这些新闻播报是初中的缩影，就像你在自然历史博物馆看到初中展览时的样子。有耳朵很大的小个子，害羞得满脸通红的孩子，运动员，电脑俱乐部的孩子——完全正常，超级贴心，表现超群的孩子。还有那些对自己的烂笑话感到过于自豪的孩子。看着他们很有趣。我忘了初中生可以有这种过分自信的傻气。
I spent days watching kids deliver these newscasts. And I was curious what they'd be like if they actually reported on the stories that mattered the most to them, stuff they'd never say on the morning announcements, the big headlines in their school that week.
我花了几天时间看孩子们播报这些新闻。我很好奇，如果他们真的报道那些对他们最重要的故事，他们会在早间广播里永远不会说的事情，那一周学校的大标题，会是什么样子。
Amanda, you need to get out of my shot.
阿曼达，你需要从我的镜头里走开。
So I found a school that was willing to play along. Parkville Middle School is just north of Baltimore, and the students there do their morning announcements as a six-minute show called PTV. With the help of their teacher, Ms. Davis, the kids put out a really involved production. There are three TV cameras, a control room, and the anchors sit at one of those giant news desks. It has a PTV logo on it. Behind them, there's a backdrop of downtown Baltimore.
所以我找了一所愿意配合的学校。帕克维尔初中就在巴尔的摩北部，那里的学生把他们的早间播报做成了一个名为PTV的六分钟节目。在老师戴维斯女士的帮助下，孩子们制作了一个非常投入的作品。有三台电视摄像机，一个控制室，主播坐在那张巨大的新闻桌后面。桌上有PTV标志。在他们身后，是巴尔的摩市中心的背景。
Girls, don't forget to watch your hair. I see yours, Amanda, sitting right on your mic.
女孩们，别忘了照看好你们的头发。阿曼达，我看到你的头发正搭在麦克风上。
With Ms. Davis's help, I enlisted the kids in this experiment to write up a newscast with news from their lives and the stories they each cared about. And they delivered. They said they had fun doing it.
在戴维斯女士的帮助下，我让孩子们参加了这个实验，写一份包含他们生活中的新闻以及他们每个人关心的故事的新闻稿。他们做到了。他们说做这个很有趣。
So I've heard that there is a new Martin Luther King Jr. statue in Washington, DC. That statue doesn't even look him. It looks like he has a uni-brow.
所以我听说在华盛顿特区有一座新的马丁·路德·金雕像。那座雕像看起来根本不像他。看起来他有一个连在一起的眉毛。
Our school is getting their boiler fixed. And they talked over the announcements like it was an important thing. But it didn't really sound important to me. But I guess they thought it was important for some students and the teachers.
我们学校的锅炉正在修理。他们在广播里谈论它，好像这是一件重要的事情。但对我来说听起来并不是很重要。但我猜他们认为这对一些学生和老师来说很重要。
Kids were randomly clapping at lunch, and the teachers got fed up. So last week, a rule was made that you're not allowed to clap. So at lunch, this one kid, Raymond, clapped. I think he got suspended.
孩子们在午餐时随机鼓掌，老师们受够了。所以上周定了一个规矩，不准鼓掌。结果午餐时，一个叫雷蒙德的孩子鼓了掌。我想他被停学了。
The US Department of Agriculture is banning potatoes from school lunches. I love potatoes. They can just make them healthier or something. They don't have to ban them.
美国农业部禁止学校午餐提供土豆。我喜欢土豆。他们完全可以把它们做得更健康一些。没必要禁止。
The weather has been terribly cold lately. I've had to wear my Uggs boots five times in the past three weeks. I swear if I find any dirt on them anywhere, Mother Nature is going to hear from me.
最近天气冷得要命。我过去三周里不得不穿了五次我的UGG靴子。我发誓如果我在上面发现任何一点灰尘，大自然母亲就会听到我的声音。
So over the weekend, my best friend told me he's still going trick or treating. He says he is going with a friend from school. Personally, I think we're all too old to be trick or treating. Well, that is all I have for today. I'm Billy Cochran. Have a good day.
所以周末时，我最好的朋友告诉我他还要去不给糖就捣蛋。他说他要和学校的一个朋友一起去。个人觉得，我们都太大了，不适合再做那种事了。好了，这就是我今天要说的全部内容。我是比利·科克伦。祝大家愉快。
Zakia Bryant decided to go hyper local with her news. She wears glasses, and she had her hair pulled back with a headband.
扎基亚·布莱恩特决定做她个人的超本地新闻。她戴着眼镜，用发带把头发扎在后面。
In local news, aka here at Parkville Middle, there is a lot of drama going on. Me personally, I lost most of my friends. I really miss those chicks, but I don't think they feel the same. Kaylynn and Jaya were my besties, and now they're gone. I still love them though. They're my sisters. Well, I don't really have too much more to say, because my life is kind of boring, so deuces.
本地新闻，也就是帕克维尔初中这边，有很多戏码在上演。我个人呢，失去了大部分朋友。我真的很想念那些小妞，但我觉得她们感觉不一样了。凯琳和贾亚曾经是我最好的闺蜜，现在她们走了。不过我依然爱她们。她们是我的姐妹。好了，我没太多要说的了，因为我的生活有点无聊，所以再见啦。
Zakia and I talked for a while. She told me that "deuces" was just another way of saying, "peace out."
扎基亚和我聊了一会儿。她告诉我“再见啦”（deuces）只是“再见”（peace out）的另一种说法。
Can I ask you about your friends? What happened?
我可以问问关于你朋友的事吗？发生了什么？
Well, it was a lot of drama going on. Some things got said, and people's feelings got hurt. And some of us made up. Some of us didn't. But I hope that we can. It sucks.
嗯，发生了很多戏码。说了一些话，伤害了人的感情。我们中的一些人言归于好。一些人没有。但我希望我们可以。这太糟糕了。
So you're just not talking to them at all.
所以你们完全不说话了。
Well actually, she's not talking to me, because I called her a name and it hurt her feelings. So she's very upset with me. I just need to apologize. I didn't do that yet. I feel kind of bad about that, so I'm going to.
其实是她不跟我说话，因为我叫了她一个外号，这伤害了她的感情。所以她对我非常生气。我只是需要道歉。我还没来得及。我对此感觉有点糟糕，所以我打算去道歉。
The very last kid I talked to was Jaya Wadi. She sandwiched her most surprising news in between a couple other stories.
最后一个和我交谈的孩子是贾亚·瓦迪。她把她最令人惊讶的新闻夹在其他两个故事中间。
My brother goes to Penn State, and he's on the football team. And I've been to all the home games, and they're a lot of fun. The students are crazy, and they get dressed up in blue and white. It's really cool. So my friend is always depressed, and then she's mad at me all the time. So I don't understand that. I was watching the news the other day, and they were talking about how President Obama--
我哥哥在宾夕法尼亚州立大学上学，是足球队的。我去看过所有主场比赛，非常有意思。学生们很疯狂，穿着蓝色和白色的衣服。真的很酷。所以我的朋友总是很沮丧，然后她总是对我生气。所以我不理解这一点。我前几天看新闻，他们还在讨论奥巴马总统——
Did you catch that about her better depressed friend? I asked Jaya if it was hard to write about her.
你注意到关于她沮丧朋友的那段了吗？我问贾亚写关于她的事是否很难。
Yeah, because I didn't want to hurt her feelings, but she really doesn't care, because she said she wrote about me too.
是的，因为我不想伤害她的感情，但她真的不在乎，因为她说她也写了关于我的事。
Oh, this is--
噢，这是——
Zakia.
扎基亚。
Yeah, wow, I didn't realize that her friends she was talking about were in this class.
是的，哇，我没意识到她谈论的那些朋友就在这个班里。
Yeah, we are. But I've known her since fifth grade, so we fight a lot. But we always wind up being friends in the end.
是的，我们在。但我从五年级就认识她了，所以我们经常吵架。但最后我们总是会和好。
What happened exactly?
到底发生了什么？
Nothing really, just people telling other people things, spreading rumors and drama, middle school.
没什么，只是人们告诉别人一些事情，散布流言蜚语和戏码，这就是初中。
Ms. Davis, the journalism teacher at Parkville Middle, is always stressing that her students be factual and truthful in their stories. The news isn't rumors and opinions. But in middle school, sometimes it's hard to remember that. It's hard to step back and look at a story from different perspectives.
帕克维尔初中的新闻老师戴维斯女士总是强调学生在故事中要真实可靠。新闻不是流言蜚语和观点。但在初中，有时很难记住这一点。很难退后一步，从不同的角度看待一个故事。
Jonathan Menjivar is one of the producers of our show.
乔纳森·门吉瓦尔是我们的制作人之一。
Act Five, Blue Kid On the Block. In September, a kid who we're going to call Leo-- not his real name-- started seventh grade at a new school. And he's having a more extreme experience. He's having a harder time finding his place in middle school than other middle school kids, because he's new to town. His family just arrived from Rochester, New York. He's got that on top of everything else.
第五幕：街区里的忧郁孩子。九月，一个我们要称之为里奥的孩子——不是他的真名——在新的学校开始了七年级。他有着更极端的经历。他比其他初中生更难在初中找到自己的位置，因为他是外地来的。他的家庭刚从纽约州罗切斯特搬来。除此之外，他还要处理其他一切事情。
Leo still loves Rochester. He loved his school there. He loved his friends. Suddenly, everything about his life is different, and, according to Leo, much worse.
里奥仍然热爱罗切斯特。他爱他在那里的学校。他爱他的朋友。突然间，他生活中的一切都变了，而且根据里奥的说法，变糟多了。
The signature on his Gmail account now reads, "Rochester is much better" in big, red letters. Sarah Koenig knows Leo and his parents, and visited them at home to see how Leo was doing.
他的Gmail账户现在的签名写着，“罗切斯特好多了”，用的是红色的醒目大号字体。莎拉·科尼希认识里奥和他的父母，并到他们家拜访，看看里奥过得怎么样。
This is how much Leo does not want to be here. When I got to his house, he was on the sofa with a laptop investigating Greyhound bus schedules. His mother was going to drive him and his sister back to Rochester for the Columbus Day weekend, but not until Saturday morning. And Leo wanted to get there Friday for more time with his friends. A multi-stage negotiation followed with his dad, and for one thing, a bus ticket cost money.
这就是里奥有多不想待在这里的程度。当我到达他家时，他正坐在沙发上，用笔记本电脑查询灰狗巴士的时刻表。他母亲本来要开车带他和姐姐回罗切斯特过哥伦布日周末，但要到周六早上才走。而里奥想在周五就到达那里，多和朋友待一会儿。一场多阶段的谈判随之与他父亲展开，首先，一张汽车票是要钱的。
That's not a problem.
那不是问题。
Not for you, no. That wasn't a problem for you.
对你来说不是，不。那对你来说不是问题。
No, but--
不，但是——
There isn't one, right?
根本没有，对吧？
There isn't one at 6:15 in the morning, and you won't let me miss school on Friday.
早上6点15分没有，而且你不会让我周五不去上学。
The bus takes eight hours. Even if you left at noon, you'd be there-- say you going to do the math? That's excellent.
巴士要走八个小时。即使你中午走，你也会到那里——你是打算算算账吗？那太棒了。
Never mind that the bus takes twice as long as driving, and never mind that Leo would be alone and have to change buses, and that his parents had no intention of letting him go through with this plan. But it's the kind of negotiation you indulge when your kid is miserable. And Leo is miserable. He told me right away he was, and that he had been from the moment he got here in August.
别管巴士需要的时间比开车多一倍，也别管里奥将不得不一个人走，还得换乘巴士，更别管他父母根本没打算让他执行这个计划。但这正是当你的孩子感到痛苦时，你会纵容的那种谈判。而里奥非常痛苦。他一见到我就告诉了我，从他在八月来到这里的那一刻起，他就一直很痛苦。
Is this the first time in your life where you felt like you've been sad about something for this long?
这是你人生中第一次感觉到为某件事悲伤这么久吗？
I think so, except for maybe when my other cat died, my old cat.
我想是的，除了可能是我另一只猫去世时，我以前那只猫。
And does this feel worse than that?
这感觉比那次更糟吗？
Yes. I've never had long periods of sadness until now. I don't know. I don't know anyone here really, and I think it's just everything in general. It's overwhelming.
是的。直到现在，我从没经历过这么长时间的悲伤。我不知道。我在这里基本上谁也不认识，我想是总体上的这一切。这太让人难以承受了。
Back in Rochester, Leo had known all his best friends since kindergarten, or before. They played together at school, after school, on weekends. Everybody knew everybody. Everything was comfortable. And as a sixth grader in his old school, he and his friends were at the top of the heap. They wore green sashes in the morning, and got to be door monitors for the younger kids coming into the building.
回到罗切斯特，里奥从幼儿园或者更早的时候起就认识了他所有的好朋友。他们在学校、课后、周末都在一起玩。每个人都认识每个人。一切都很舒适。作为他旧学校的六年级学生，他和朋友们处在食物链的顶端。他们早上系着绿色饰带，还得负责监护进入大楼的低年级学生。
So imagine now, Leo takes a school bus for the first time to his new school, a sprawling, one story building full of sixth, seventh, and eighth graders. Leo is small for his age, only a hair taller than his sister, who's only nine years old. On day one, he knows exactly no one.
所以现在想象一下，里奥第一次坐校车去他的新学校，这是一座蔓延的、一层楼高的建筑，满是六年级、七年级和八年级的学生。里奥在同龄人中个子很小，只比他九岁的姐姐高一点点。第一天，他一个人也不认识。
It was much louder than my old school, much louder, people talking, people closing and opening lockers, people walking. It was just noise. Just older kids, more kids, because my old school was tiny.
这比我旧学校吵得多，吵得多，人们在谈话，人们关开储物柜，人们在走路。到处都是噪音。就是大孩子，更多孩子，因为我的旧学校很小。
Leo is between. He's old enough to decipher Greyhound bus schedules, but not old enough to actually travel on one by himself. And old enough to know that if he's going to survive in middle school, he has to make friends, but that making those friends stands to be significantly more complicated than it was back in Rochester. Leo's sister, Auden, is in fourth grade. He says she's not having as hard a time of it.
里奥正处于中间阶段。他大到可以破译灰狗巴士时刻表，但不够大到可以独自乘车。他足够大到知道如果他想在初中活下来，就必须交朋友，但交朋友这件事要比在罗切斯特时复杂得多。里奥的姐姐奥登在上四年级。他说她没那么痛苦。
She hasn't been alive as long. She hasn't made as deep connections. And she already met a friend in her school. I think it's easier to make friends in elementary school than in middle school.
她没活那么久。她没建立那么深的联系。而且她已经在学校交到一个朋友了。我觉得在小学交朋友比在初中容易。
Oh really? Why?
噢真的吗？为什么？
Because people care less about who you are.
因为人们没那么在意你是谁。
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
The older you get, the more you judge people on their looks, their background, how they act, like what cool is for kids. Because in kindergarten, you could just walk up to someone and say, "Do you want to be my friend?" And that would be it. But it's harder. I just think people are more wary before they open up. Like in first grade, if I met someone, I woulnd't really care who they were. I would just care if they were nice or not.
你越大，人们就越根据你的外表、你的背景、你的行为来评判你，比如什么是酷。因为在幼儿园，你可以直接走到一个人面前说：“你想做我的朋友吗？”然后就行了。但现在难多了。我只是觉得人们在敞开心扉之前更谨慎。就像一年级时，如果我见到一个人，我真的不在意他们是谁。我只在意他们是否善良。
The day I interviewed him, Leo had had a couple of breakthroughs. He emailed his parents during the school day to tell them the first piece of good news they'd had from him. Until that day, the emails had mostly been three desperate words, "I feel awful," without even a period at the end to make the feeling finite. It was an endless awful. But on this Thursday, he wrote to tell them the mashed potatoes they serve in the cafeteria were great, followed by four exclamation points.
我采访他的那天，里奥取得了一些突破。他在上课期间给父母发邮件，告诉他们他传来的第一个好消息。在那之前，这些邮件基本上都是三个绝望的词，“我感觉糟糕透了”，甚至连结尾的句号都没有，没法让这种感觉变得有限。这是一种无尽的糟糕。但在这个周四，他写信告诉他们食堂供应的土豆泥很棒，后面跟着四个感叹号。
Second, and this was the big news, he asked another kid if he wanted to come over. Leo told me he thought about it first for a few days, and finally emailed the boy, whose name is Devin, another seventh grader. But now, Leo didn't want to call Devin's house to finalize a plan. He dreaded the awkwardness of the phone. So his dad called Devin's parents, introduced himself as Leo's father.
第二，这是个大新闻，他问另一个孩子是否想去他家玩。里奥告诉我他先考虑了几天，最后给那个名叫德文的男孩发了邮件，德文也是七年级的。但现在，里奥不想打电话去德文家确认计划。他害怕电话里的尴尬。所以他父亲给德文的父母打了电话，自我介绍是里奥的父亲。
[ON PHONE] He goes to school with your son Evan, and we were-- Devin, I'm so sorry, Devin. I'm getting the evil look from my son. I apologize. But we're hoping Devin can come over on Sunday. Thanks. [OFF PHONE] I panicked.
[电话中] 他和你儿子埃文在一所学校，我们正在——德文，我很抱歉，德文。我从我儿子那里收到了恶狠狠的眼神。我很抱歉。但我们希望德文周日能过来玩。谢谢。[挂断电话] 我惊慌失措了。
You fool.
你这傻瓜。
How'd that go?
进展怎么样？
Not well. [LAUGHTER]
不太好。[笑声]
My son Freddy.
我儿子弗雷迪。
I thought Leo might be upset about it, maybe get sulky. But here he was cracking up, joking with his dad. It was such a relief to hear him laugh after he'd been so solemn in our interview. And I thought this is all going to be OK. He's going to snap out of it. He's almost there. An afternoon with Devin is going to do the trick. Then Sunday came.
我以为里奥可能会为此难过，也许会生闷气。但他现在却在大笑，和他父亲开玩笑。听到他在我们采访中表现得那么严肃后发出笑声，真是一种解脱。我想这一切都会好起来的。他会走出来的。他快成功了。下午和德文玩一场游戏会奏效的。然后周日到了。
OK, now I have three health again.
好的，现在我的健康值又满了。
I think you're becoming a wolf.
我觉得你要变成狼人了。
OK, I'm going to tell my wolf to attack then.
好的，我要让我的狼发起攻击。
Leo taught Devin how to play Dungeons and Dragons .
里奥教了德文怎么玩《龙与地下城》。
And the wolf lands on its feet.
那只狼落地了。
Yay, go wolfie, go wolfie, go wolfie. I am so weird.
耶，加油小狼，加油小狼，加油小狼。我真是太奇怪了。
On the drive home, Leo and Devin talk nonstop, a gentle rat-a-tat, one-up-manship emanating from deep inside a computer game.
开车回家的路上，里奥和德文一直在聊天，一种温和的、像机枪似的争强好胜的声音从电脑游戏深处传出来。
I am a blood elf, warlock.
我是个血精灵，术士。
I had a goblin shaman.
我有个地精萨满。
I'm a knight-elf druid, and I can turn into a cat at level 8, which is nice. And at level 12, you get a bear.
我是个暗夜精灵德鲁伊，我8级时可以变身成猫，这很棒。12级时，你可以得到一只熊。
By the time they dropped Devin off, they were giggling.
当他们把德文放下车时，他们还在傻笑。
Our cat responds to whatever you call him. We say his name is [UNINTELLIGIBLE], or you can call him football. Here Football. Here Football.
我们的猫对你叫它什么都有反应。我们说他的名字是[无法辨认]，或者你可以叫他“足球”。来吧足球。来吧足球。
Thanks for coming over.
谢谢你过来。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thank you for inviting me.
谢谢你邀请我。
See you tomorrow.
明天见。
See you.
见。
So a perfect day, right? Leo's parents were relieved, hopeful, but no.
所以这是完美的一天，对吧？里奥的父母松了一口气，充满希望，但并没有。
It's Wednesday. You had your friend over on Sunday. How'd it go?
是周三了。你周日朋友来玩了。进展如何？
It went OK. Yeah, it went OK.
还行吧。是的，还行。
Has it changed anything about being here?
这改变了你在这里的状况吗？
A little bit. I don't think very much, but a little bit, yeah.
一点点吧。我觉得变化不大，但有一点，是的。
What's changed? What's the little bit?
改变了什么？哪一点点？
That I know someone at school. It helps. Not all that much, but sort of, yeah.
因为我在学校认识了人。这有帮助。虽然没那么大帮助，但有一点，是的。
And this is when I realized I had underestimated the depth of Leo's gloom, that he greets every morning of every school day with dread. And not because he's being bullied or anyone's being mean to him.
就在这时我意识到，我低估了里奥忧郁的深度，他每天上学的早晨都是在恐惧中度过的。并不是因为他被欺负，或者有人对他刻薄。
I feel sick, because I know that I have the whole day ahead of me, and then I have the next day and the next day and the next day and the next day and the next day ahead of me.
我感觉很难受，因为我知道接下来的一整天都等着我，然后明天也是，后天也是，之后每一天都等着我。
Does it pass once you get to school?
到了学校后这种情况会消失吗？
No, not really. It usually increases to a climax around lunchtime, and then I-- actually, I've been throwing up recently. And then it just stays that level of sickness until I get home.
不，不会。它通常在午餐时间达到高潮，然后我——其实，我最近一直在呕吐。然后那种恶心的感觉就一直保持着，直到我回家。
You're kidding me. You're throwing up at school?
你在开玩笑吧。你在学校呕吐？
Yeah.
是的。
That's awful. In the bathroom or where?
那太可怕了。是在洗手间还是哪？
Yeah, in the bathroom. Usually at lunch I feel really bad. And I go to the bathroom and I throw up.
是的，在洗手间。通常午餐时我感觉特别糟。我就去洗手间吐了。
Has that happened this week?
这周发生了吗？
Today it did.
今天发生了。
Do you tell your parents, I don't want to go. I want to go. Or do you just-- you know you have to, so you don't say anything?
你会告诉父母，我不想去。我不想去。还是你只是——你知道你必须去，所以你什么都不说？
No, I throw a screaming fit.
不，我会大发雷霆。
Every morning?
每天早上？
Yeah, pretty much. I didn't today.
是的，差不多。今天没发火。
What was different about this morning? How come you didn't today?
今天早上有什么不同？你怎么今天没发火？
I felt resigned. I knew that I would have to go anyway, so I gave up.
我感到认命了。我知道无论如何都得去，所以我放弃了。
Here's the curse of being almost 13, old enough to understand his life will supposedly get better with time, but not old enough to really believe he's going to feel any differently than he does right this minute. Since making friends with Devin, Leo is one step toward being the kid he wants to be, someone with pals, someone who's comfortable again. But he says right now, he's just worried he's going to be throwing up all year.
这就是快13岁的诅咒，他大到可以明白生活会随着时间推移好转，但又没大到能真正相信他现在的感受会有所不同。自从和德文交朋友后，里奥向着他想成为的孩子迈出了一步，一个有伙伴的孩子，一个重新感到舒适的孩子。但他说现在，他只是担心他这一整年都要在呕吐中度过。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show.
莎拉·科尼希是我们的制作人之一。
Act Six, Grande With Sugar. So I've been talking to educators, and one who had taught for years in high school and then moved to middle school told me that the key difference between teaching in the two environments was that in middle school, you have to be sympathetic to, and patient with, all of the emotional drama. You have to deal with that directly if you want the classroom to work. Which brings me to this next story of a student who was doing badly in a middle school in Newark, New Jersey.
第六幕：加糖的大杯。所以我和教育工作者聊过，一位曾在高中教书多年然后转到初中工作的老师告诉我，两个环境之间教学的关键区别在于，在初中，你必须对所有的情感戏码表现出同情和耐心。如果你想让课堂运作起来，你必须直接处理这些。这让我想到了下一个故事，关于新泽西州纽瓦克市一所初中里表现不佳的学生。
He was a mess. He would come in. His uniform would be dirty. He hadn't showered. He hadn't had breakfast. His book bag most likely had a hole in it, and all of his pens and pencils had fallen out. His homework wasn't done. And so of course, he'd come in and he'd be angry.
他一团糟。他会走进来。他的制服很脏。他没洗澡。没吃早饭。他的书包很可能有个洞，所有的笔和铅笔都掉出来了。作业没做。当然，他会走进来，然后他会很生气。
This is Shannon Grande, who teaches at Rise Academy Middle School, which is a public school, 91% black and Latino, and eligible for free lunches, one of the KIPP charter schools. Hence the uniforms.
这位是香农·格兰德，她在Rise Academy初中任教，那是一所公立学校，91%的黑人和拉丁裔，符合免费午餐资格，属于KIPP特许学校之一。所以有制服。
I heard about this story from Elizabeth Green, who had been reporting on this school for a journalism outfit called Gotham Schools. Anyway, this teacher, Sharon Grande, says that this seventh grader would come in angry all the time.
我是从伊丽莎白·格林那里听到这个故事的，她曾为一家名为“哥谭学校”的新闻机构报道这所学校。总之，这位老师莎伦·格兰德说，这个七年级的学生总是带着怒气进来。
And usually some would say something little to him like, "Your shirt's not tucked in."
通常会有人对他说些小话，比如“你的衬衫没塞进去”。
Another kid would?
另一个孩子说的？
Yeah, because they do that. They just kind of pick at each other. And it would set him off. And then he would just be very loud, and just be like, "Oh, why do you always have to say this to me?" And slam his stuff down, "I hate this place." And he'd just go into these very general rants. And usually that's an indicator to us, when they use those very general statements, that they're not processing through their emotions, that they're feeling overwhelmed.
是的，因为他们就那样。他们只是互相挑剔。这会让他爆发。然后他会非常大声，就像说，“噢，你们为什么总是要这样对我？”然后把他的东西砸在桌上，“我讨厌这个地方。”他就开始陷入这种非常笼统的咆哮中。通常那是给我们的一种指标，当他们使用那些非常笼统的陈述时，意味着他们没有处理好自己的情绪，意味着他们感到不堪重负。
So this kid was in an unfortunate spiral. He felt isolated from the other kids just inherently, because his home situation was so bad. And then would get angry with the other kids, which then made them mad and made him more isolated. Then he got worse and worse, threw some stuff across a room, and it hit a teacher.
所以这个孩子陷入了不幸的恶性循环。他天生就感到与其他孩子隔绝，因为他的家庭状况太糟糕了。然后他会对其他孩子生气，这又让他们生气，使他更加孤立。然后他变得越来越糟，在房间里扔了一些东西，砸到了老师。
And there were points where he would come in, and he would refuse to do anything all day long. And he'd cry. He would break down and cry in the middle of class. He didn't even know why.
有时他会走进来，拒绝整天做任何事。他会哭。他会在课堂中间崩溃大哭。他甚至不知道为什么。
And he couldn't explain why. Well a big problem for him, one reason that he was ostracized, he didn't wash. Kids would whisper about it, and when he would get mad and then arguments would escalate, that is where it would go. "You're dirty." "You smell." The kids would say it right to his face. Over time, the staff found all kinds of ways to address this. They found him clean clothes and a place to clean up before school.
他也解释不了为什么。他被排斥的一个大问题是，他不洗澡。孩子们会窃窃私语，当他发火，争吵升级时，矛盾点就会在那里。“你很脏。”“你闻起来很臭。”孩子们会当面这么说。随着时间的推移，教职员工找到了各种方法来解决这个问题。他们在他上学前帮他找了干净的衣服和一个清洁的地方。
But the bigger problem-- and that's the problem of his isolation and his anger-- Ms. Grande says it was not clear how to deal with that. They would try things, but nothing was working. And then finally one day in history class during group work, he was trash talking. And one of the best girls in the class, one of Ms. Grande's best students, ended up in an argument with him saying terrible things. And Ms. Grande felt like, really? You too?
但更大的问题——也就是他的孤立和愤怒问题——格兰德女士说，还不清楚如何处理。他们试过各种办法，但都没用。最后，有一天在历史课的小组作业中，他正在进行口头攻击。班里最优秀的女孩之一，也就是格兰德女士最好的学生之一，最终因为说了非常可怕的话而跟他发生了争吵。格兰德女士觉得，真的是这样吗？连你也这样？
I pulled the girl, and she was like, "Well, he brings it on. He gets angry, and then what am I supposed to say?" I was like, well you could not say that.
我把那个女孩拉到一边，她说：“嗯，是他找茬。他很生气，那我该说什么？”我说，嗯，你可以不说那些。
That being?
指的是？
That he's dirty and he smells. And she's like, "Well he does." And I said, "I think this is a bigger conversation."
说他很脏，闻起来很臭。她说，“嗯，他确实那样。”我说，“我觉得我们需要进行一次更深入的谈话。”
So Ms. Grande took this girl and the three other girls who had been doing group work with this boy, and she took those girls into the teacher's room. And all four of these girls were academically strong, and all of them had shown good leadership qualities in the school in the past. And she talked to them.
所以格兰德女士带了这个女孩和另外三个与这个男孩一起做小组作业的女孩，她把她们带进了老师的办公室。这四个女孩学业都很强，而且过去都表现出很好的领导素质。她和她们谈了谈。
I had explained to them that he struggles just to get here every day. I was like, "You wake up in the morning, and you've got somebody that's getting you out of the door, giving you breakfast, making sure your clothes are clean, making sure you get here on time. He doesn't have that. He has nobody doing that for him." And at that time, I knew that the power had been off at his house, that the week before, the water was shut off, that they had had part of their roof cave in.
我向她们解释说，他每天为了能来上学都要进行挣扎。我说，“你们早上醒来，有人叫你们起床，给你们做早饭，确保你们的衣服干净，确保你们准时到达学校。他没有人为他做这些。”在那时，我知道他家断电了，前一周水也被停了，他们屋顶的一部分塌了。
He has an elderly grandmother that he tries to take care of, and she had been getting up in the middle of the night and wandering. And he would hear her and get up and carry her back upstairs.
他有一个年迈的祖母，他试图照顾她，而她会在半夜起床游荡。他会听见她，然后起床把她抱回楼上。
What was their reaction?
她们的反应是什么？
Empathy. She's like, "I didn't know that." And the other girls there were talking about that. And I was like, "I'm telling you something that I normally wouldn't tell another student. This is something very private. But I'm trusting that you're mature enough to handle this." And I was like, "So you're kind of breaking him down when you're doing these things." And she's like, "Well, can we talk to him?"
同理心。她说，“我不知道这些。”其他女孩也在谈论这件事。我说，“我告诉你们的事情，通常情况下我不会告诉其他学生。这是非常私人的事。但我信任你们，相信你们足够成熟，能够处理这件事。”然后我说，“所以你们在做这些事情时是在打压他。”她说，“嗯，我们可以和他谈谈吗？”
I was a little nervous obviously. I was really worried about it. I was like, what am I doing here? This could be really dangerous and backfire on me terribly. They started to talk, and they were like, "When you get angry, we get angry back. What do you expect us to say?"
我显然很紧张。我真的很担心。我想，我在这里做什么？这可能非常危险，并产生可怕的后果。她们开始谈话，她们说，“当你生气时，我们也反过来生气。你期望我们说什么？”
And it really was just a couple minutes before the kids told Ms. Grande, "We can take it from here." And she left them to talk. Afterwards, the boy told Ms. Grande that it felt good. It felt good that these girls knew that he was trying to deal with his anger. And since this conversation, over time, the entire class has entered this discussion with this kid. And when this kid has an outburst, they will all talk openly about his anger.
这确实只过了几分钟，孩子们就告诉格兰德女士，“我们能自己处理了。”她留她们谈话。之后，那个男孩告诉格兰德女士说，感觉很好。感觉很好，因为这些女孩知道他在试图处理自己的愤怒。从这次对话开始，随着时间的推移，整个班级都加入了与这个孩子的讨论。当这个孩子情绪爆发时，他们会公开谈论他的愤怒。
The students say, "Well, you've told us you're working on this. What are you going to do differently now?" And then he'd try to explain, "Well, I'm trying to take deep breaths. I'm trying to journal when I'm getting angry." And he'd come up with whatever solutions he was trying to do.
学生们说，“嗯，你告诉过我们你正在努力解决这个问题。你现在打算做点什么不同的事情？”然后他会试着解释，“嗯，我试着做深呼吸。我试着在生气时写日记。”他会想出他正在尝试的任何解决方案。
But a lot of times even, it wasn't about the solution. The peer pressure itself, and the feeling like-- he had come in, and he's making these general statements like "everybody's against me." And then he's starting to feel like, OK, maybe everybody isn't against me. Maybe they are just frustrated with this behavior that I'm doing that I could be doing better. And we started to see that impact of peer pressure.
但很多时候，这甚至不是关于解决方案的问题。同伴压力本身，以及那种感觉——他进来，他做了这些笼统的陈述，比如“每个人都针对我”。然后他开始觉得，好吧，也许并非每个人都针对我。也许他们只是对我表现出的这种行为感到沮丧，而我本来是可以做得更好的。我们开始看到同伴压力的影响。
Well, it's like you took the entire machinery of middle school dynamics, and you're harnessing it to help this kid.
嗯，这就像是你利用了初中社交动态的整个机制，并且你正在利用它来帮助这个孩子。
Exactly.
没错。
Harness the fact that they'll listen to peers.
利用他们会听同伴的话这一事实。
Exactly, and we know they do.
没错，而且我们知道他们会听。
This is what the research shows, that in middle school, you listen to peers more than you listen to anybody else. And that is working with this kid. The other day, this kid got a detention for missing part of his uniform. And he started on a rant in class about how they're all against him, and all the time they're on his back, and everybody's against him. And it was the end of the world. And Ms. Grande finally asked him, "Who's they? Who's everybody?" And he started smiling. And she asked him what is he really upset about? And unlike in the past, he could untangle it. He could tell her.
这就是研究显示的内容，在初中，比起任何人，你听同伴的话更多。这在帮助这个孩子。前几天，这个孩子因为没穿全制服被罚留校。他在课堂上开始咆哮，说他们都在针对他，一直找他麻烦，每个人都在针对他。好像世界末日一样。格兰德女士最后问他，“他们是谁？每个人又是谁？”他开始笑了。她问他到底在为什么生气？和过去不同，他能理清思路了。他能告诉她了。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak, with Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Mickey Meek. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our officer manager. Music help from Damien Grave. Our website, thisamericanlife.org.
好的，我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克制作，参与制作的有本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·科尼希、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。米奇·米克提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿是我们的办公室经理。达米安·格雷提供了音乐帮助。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who gets so confused at the beginning of every HR meeting.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目由老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生进行管理监督，他在每次人力资源会议开始时都很困惑。
They give you the dress code, and they give you the rules, "no petting." And it's in quotations.
他们给你着装要求，然后给你规则：“不能有爱抚行为”。而且是加了引号的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。